howdy when your doctor orders a blood
test it comes back with his fuse and 20
parameters to analyze but modern
genomics technologies can measure the
expression of fall with 20,000 human
genes in a single experiment how can a
doctor process all this information let
alone make a decision on how to treat a
patient now imagine a doctor who
measures the expression of every human
gene in 50 cancer patients and 50
healthy people the doctor gives this
data to you a computer scientist but
doesn't tell you with each of the
hundred data sets correspond to the 50
cancer patients why does the doctor hide
from you who've each data correspond to
cancer patients because if you can
correctly separate all data into healthy
and cancer clusters in a blind
experiment that you can potentially
determine with a new patient as cancer
just from that patient gene expression
data perhaps your diagnostic can
identify cancer even before the patients
show any symptoms of cancer
revolutionary cancer diagnostics like
this are being developed today including
the breast cancer diagnostic llama prep
which can predict a patient's likelihood
of breast cancer recurrence based on the
expression of just 70 genes a related
biological problem is to partition
thousands of individual human genomes
into clusters in order to identify a
genomic basis of ethnicity we can then
start to answer questions about your
genetic heritage as well as determine
whether you like me have any Neanderthal
DNA these two biological problems fall
under the same computational framework
of assigning data points to clusters so
that elements in the same cluster are
similar and elements in different
clusters are dissimilar this problem may
seem simple but it quickly becomes a
major challenge when we attempt to apply
clustering methods to biological
problems which range from finding genes
responsible for this
and clock to clustering yeast genes in
order to determine which ones are
responsible for winemaking we hope that
you will join us in this class to learn
about these challenges of clustering
biological data
although these instructors may appear
crazy they are not quite as mad as they
look dr. Pavel peb snare is a
distinguished professor of computer
science at the University of California
San Diego and a leading authority on
bioinformatics he's dressed this way
because he sometimes thinks that he's a
sheriff of bioinformatics a frontier
discipline underpinning the digital
revolution in biology and personalized
medicine dr. Phillip Campo is an
assistant professor of computer science
at Carnegie Mellon University to learn
why he is dressed this way you'll need
to take this course or read the textbook
bioinformatics algorithms and active
learning approach co-authored by the two
speakers